>>Okay, so now what
games did you make?
How do you win this game?
>>There's still like the score.
It's like one hundred
points per shot.
>>Narrator: At this end of
semester fair at Google headquarters
in Mountain View, California,
dozens of middle school students
are presenting work they've done
in after school apprenticeships,
to an audience of parents,
teachers, and business people.
>>That is so cool.
>>Narrator: Similar events around
the country celebrate the work
of Citizen Schools, which
operates a national network
of apprenticeship programs
for middle school students,
connecting adult volunteers to
young people with hands on projects.
>>We need to take a whole different
look at how we do education,
and do more enrichment and really get
back to looking at the whole child.
>>Narrator: Citizen Schools
co-founder, Eric Schwarz,
believes education is everyone's job.
>>I think this is a big idea, and
the idea of tapping into millions
of citizen teachers and mentors,
and democratizing what it means
to be a teacher in America,
is the wave of the future.
>>At its essence, Citizen Schools
partners with public schools
to expand the learning day and
then fill up that longer day
with all kinds of cool stuff
that turns kids on to learning,
and helps them be successful.
>>So you can add a
little bit of blue.
>>Students spend three
hours, four days a week
in Citizen School after
school programs.
Two times a week, they
work with mentors
in their chosen apprenticeship.
>>So you're gonna hold
the bezel roller--
>>In the remaining time, paid Citizen
Schools staff teachers offer students
homework help and coach them
on school navigation skills.
>>When I go to Citizen School,
the next day, I listen more,
I practice more what I'm doing,
math, sciences, and reading.
>>I now know that I can do so many
things and it's fun doing them.
>>Francisco: [translation] My
daughter has improved her English
and her ability to
express herself in public.
>>I'm very pleased with the
program because it has helped her
with everything, her studies
and her class participation.
>>How to make it double.
>>Yeah, so we double them up, right.
>>The internships cover
a wide spectrum,
from jewelry making
to robotics to sewing.
>>And now you have to do the
same thing for the other one too.
>>I love sewing.
I've been sewing half of my life
and I am happy to share what I know
with the kids, and they
seem to be liking it,
enjoying it, and they're learning.
You can see it.
>>We know what you're gonna teach.
We know the skills that you
want the kids to get out of it.
We--
>>In a three hour session,
before the semester begins,
Citizen Schools trainers help the
volunteer mentors refine what they're
like to teach.
>>So if you wanna teach computers,
let's narrow that down
to web design--
>>And mentors receive staff
support throughout the semester.
>>Some Citizen teachers need a lot
of support, ones who haven't worked
with kids before, especially
when we go to different places,
like a law office or Google.
It's my role to support them,
however they need to be supported.
>>They've been good about
making regular contact
with me once a week just to see
how things are, helping me sort
of in a gentle way to sort of develop
my ability to organize how I teach
and what I teach a little bit better,
given that I'm not a professional
by any stretch of the imagination.
>>Well, there's two things I
can think of right off the bat.
>>Google software engineer,
Doug Felt,
taught a robotics apprenticeship.
>>As a software engineer, I
spend a lot of my time dealing
with very intricate,
detailed things and this is
so completely separate from that.
It's personal, it's
immediate, and gives me a chance
to do something different
that is giving
to the community in some sense.
>>Citizen Schools introduces the
talented adults in a community,
who probably don't have kids in
that school and kinda connects them
to kids in that school and
allows them to be a resource.
And that's exciting, because I think
too often, schools are isolated
from the larger community.
>>The after school program
forges a community of volunteers,
parents, teachers and students.
>>I talk to their teachers once
a week to keep up on homework
and how they're doing and
then I talk to the kids
about what their teachers say.
Also I talk to their parents once
every two weeks and sorta update them
on how the kids are doing in program,
you know, socially and academically,
and also what their teachers have
said, to sort of complete the circle
between everyone involved.
>>And then where does the chain go?
>>The chain will go into the--
>>It's win-win for me, because it's
just like I have an expanded staff,
and so everybody is a team.
Everybody is focused on a
connection between the classroom
and the after school program.
And I think that the real key to the
Citizen Schools' success is the fact
that the Citizen Schools staff
is considered part of our staff.
So when the students
see them walking around,
they don't consider them any
different than the teachers
or anybody else that's on our
campus, and so it's seamless.
>>You're still working
on your pictures, right?
>>The Citizen Schools program has
also generated positive results
in the form of higher
attendance rates and test scores.
>>We're trying to pack more and
more stuff into a fixed six hour day
in the schools, and achievement is
highly variable and Citizen Schools,
by turning that around and saying
achievement ought to be fixed
at a high level, time ought
to be variable and kids ought
to have nine or ten hours to learn.
We're kind of an escape valve for
the pressure that schools are under.
>>Well, all I know is, it's
better than my last program,
because you get to
go to explorations.
You get more time on your homework.
You get to do really cool
apprenticeships, have fun.
So at Citizen Schools,
this is the perfect place.
>>We needed the servo module, the
motors and we put those tires there
in the front so it could
make it turn faster.
>>When kids realize that the
learning has a real link to careers,
a real link to college and
a real link to these kind
of cool experts who've just
invited them into their office,
that sets off all kinds of
positive alarm bells for the kids
and really incentivizes them to
try harder, to care about school.
>>Okay, they win.
I won. Okay.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org